voilà quand je serai star des patries
demi mot
la fiche depuis le 19 janvier est ce que
bernard henri lévy a vu le film
eh bien oui il a fait mais fait rare
parce que très souvent je ne lui montre
pas les films dans lesquels j'ai joué
vous réagissez comme ans aux attaques
dont bernard-henri lévy et est l'objet
en ce moment à travers tous ces livres
qui sortent comme ça les a après ça me
semble un peu abracadabrant qu'il y en
ait tellement il y en a eu deux y'en a
encore quatre en préparation et voilà
mais mais mais heureusement je crois que
les gens n'ont pas tellement envie de
lire des gossip méchant au vu par le
petit bout de la lorgnette et donc à mon
avis les les livres ne marche pas moi je
ne sais pas assez c'est extrêmement
enfin il ya oui c'est comme une comme un
animal très beau qui courent et puis il
ya toute une meute derrière qui me le
montre vous en pensez-quoi a voulu que
tous ces bouquins sur la mariée
l'historique d'un seul coup j'ai un peu
connu ça parce qu'on a eu deux livres
qui étaient vraiment ténue est
complètement idiot il faut dire c'est
quand même il faut être honnête c'est
assez assez difficile à vivre
on a beau parce qu'on en vit dans une
société on est obligé de faire semblant
de s'en moquer mais c'est pas vrai quand
les attaques sont basses et méchante
on est quand même atteint et donc
j'imagine que bernard même si il a quand
même un peu d'habitude comme moi
d'ailleurs ça doit te coucher d'un beau
coup dès qu'il a surgi dès sa première
mission télévision quand on la veut beau
pardonnez moi mais il est beau et avec
ce but son décolleté que c'est pour les
gens non il est imberbe
bon et alors alors oui c'est vrai ça
comment se crée tout l'habitude se sont
déchaînés bonbons non mais là je ris
voilà mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
voilà c'est très très méga désagréable
et puis pourquoi pourquoi les gens quand
même autre chose à faire qu'à écrire des
livres comme ce à quoi ça sert
non mais franchement je crois que c'est
c'est quand même des commentaires des
livres
ultra médiocre et mais qui sont quand
même largement animé par la jalousie et
parlant vicois ce qui est quand même la
pression démocratique la plus forte
ces histoires vous chamboule pas trop
aérienne langues voilà voilà ben c'est
pour ça qu'on va faire une interview up
saïda auriel attention ariel qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter de pire en ce
moment en ce moment perdre les clés de
ma bagnole je dirais oui moment
brouillés les pieds dans les fils du
micro tomber sur scène un la chose comme
ça quels défauts aimeriez-vous avoir
d'être une heure par jour invisible
j'adorerais
alors comme je serai invisible je
pourrais aller partout comme une petite
souris tout écouter tout voir et vous
quels défauts aimeriez vous avoir
ouais c'est pourquoi je devrais avoir un
défaut je préfère ne pas imaginer elle
répond ariel quelle est la qualité que
vous regrettez d'avoir des d'être
parfois trop gentille ah oui qu'est-ce
qui vous donnerait envie d'être trompé
mais si ça le rendait heureux
1 voilà en quoi aimeriez-vous être
beaucoup plus nulle beaucoup plus mais
j'ai déjà dit que j'étais nul en
orthographe mais beaucoup plus à quoi ça
servirait à rien qui ne voudriez vous
pas avoir comme fan alors justement dans
l'avion en revenant tout ça là bas non
d'accord
un album non mais mais il y avait
courrier international et sur la
couverture
il y avait vraiment des gens très très
désagréable des vrais fachos et ben euh
j'ai mme rey pas les avoir comme famille
par exemple ni pinochet ni milosevic un
nid où ça m'a bel laden lit saddam
hussein ni kadhafi mais je les aurais
pas oui alors voilà quelle insulte qui
vous a fait le plus plaisir
highway l'état que wayne aux tests ça
veut dire ouais là oui ça fait bonne
qu'est ce que vous voudriez que votre
mari rate dans l'avion pour rester avec
moi
qu'est ce que vous lui interdisez que
vous faites vous même quand je ne
m'interdis rien rien avant sauf
justement de voir les mauves estime que
je tourne parfois voilà quel est le rôle
que vous êtes contente de ne pas avoir
joué
ah ben oui mais je n'ai pas dire du mal
de mes camarades marque c'est un petit
peu dans l'algérie aime bien son nom le
rôle que je suis contente de ne pas
avoir joué
ben je suis contente de ne pas avoir
jouer l'autruche dans jurassic park et
pourtant quelle belle phrase ne
dites-vous jamais je reviendrai
quel et dont le trouble où je vous vois
apparaître et que ma veulent dire et ses
soupirs pousser et ses sombres regard
que sur moi vous lancé que deux petites
les des loyauté dont le ciel est capable
à vos déloyauté n'ont rien de comparable
dans le vent je sais plus vous irez
mais voilà voilà une belle phrase que
vous dites jamais de l'espanyol samedi
au lac et talent et je ramassais qu'est
ce que vous aimeriez ariel que quelqu'un
vole ça nous vole mon coeur quelle est
la meilleure mauvaises critiques qu'on
vous ait fait alors c'est dans le figaro
elle n'a rien au dessus du bikini est
alors oui je suis fier médusé alors je
me suis posé la question malgré ce que
je devrais avoir un coeur une tête un
esprit de dieu mais non elle n'a rien au
dessus du bikini
c'est marrant comme we came ou que vous
ne connaissez pas que vous préférez
acquis balisco bora sung et ragoût de
ses ministres de faire des films a
défendu hier et hyundai est ce qu'on m'a
dit que c'était le coming out doute
en vain
même chose
car ils abusent de plus de 10
le lia jeu